for the past five years i've kept a
documented email chain that i've called
lessons and failures
and in that chain whenever i have like a
lesson that i feel like i've learned
i would email it to myself with kind of
the circumstance and you know the the
lesson so i could document it and i've
been doing that for five years this may
be the last year that i do that because
i've kind of transitioned to documenting
my thoughts on twitter uh rather than an
email chain to myself and so that's
actually grown a lot because they were
public rather than private and then
consolidated but this video is far
overdue
because it is from the lessons and
failures of 2021 and um you know
perennially this lessons and failures
videos tend to be like my number one
video for the year and so i hope you
enjoy it i'm going to be covering a vast
you know big big swath of topics during
during this video and just to give you a
little bit of context uh my name is alex
from woozy i own acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies at this point
over 100 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you i make these videos
because i'll be dead one day and there's
all be that's left and so just a couple
of major bullets from 2021 i sold the
majority stake of allen which was a
software company that we owned 100 of it
had done 12 million in trailing 12
months revenue we sold it to strategic
buyer the terms and price of the deal i
signed a non-disclosure for so i cannot
share that part but we did 12 million
leading into the sale we sold two thirds
of uh of jim launcher prestige labs
which was a company that we founded my
wife and i to american pacific group at
a 46.2 million valuation it was an
all-cash deal for us there was no earn
out there was no seller financing there
was no transition period um and those
were the terms of that deal so i was
able to do that and i negotiated in so i
could tell you guys on this level
youtube video in addition to that i
wrote and published 100 million offers
uh which to date is still the number one
bestseller for advertising for now eight
straight months or at least the time of
this video um it has nearly five
thousand five stars on amazon and a five
star uh 4.9 ranking on there which i'm
very grateful for so thank you guys part
of mosun nation for for sharing the word
i hope to continue to write more of
these books i have a lot of outlines
it's just very hard to make them
exceptional and that's why they take so
long that being said in the same 2021 we
grew tik-tok instagram youtube all to
over a hundred thousand in the uh
subscribers followers et cetera in a
year and uh grew twitter uh to twenty
thousand and ninety days all of which
without really any knowledge of these
platforms so um i'll share some of the
things that that worked for us if that
is of interest to you guys despite the
sale not including the sale money that
we got from uh all three of those exits
that i discussed we still did seven to
eight million dollars of ebitda or like
personal earnings um outside of the sale
from real estate things like that and
just from dividends from other companies
we own i sold our bentley that was the
only nice car that we owned we had an i8
but it was a gift we still have that
we'll probably end up selling it because
it's just not that practical and beyond
that i also sold
my home and so at this point i own no
personal assets and i'm leasing my life
and so that's kind of what happened last
year so let's get to the lessons because
you're like alex i don't really give a
[ __ ] about your accomplishments and i
tend to agree with you we'll dive in
together to some of the major topics i'm
going to start with some heavy hitters
and then we're going to get into the
more tactical stuff one of the heavy
hitters here is if we think about you
know betty white have you heard of betty
white she was one of the golden gals
super successful actress uh she just
died right before 100th birthday very
sad and what's interesting is that she
was kind of a meme all over the place
about how she just missed it by like 14
days but what's interesting is that you
probably haven't thought about betty
white since then or you might not even
heard of her what's interesting to me
about that is that betty white achieved
pretty much all levels of success she
was a really nice person she was a huge
human rights advocate she donated tons
of money she was famous she had like she
did everything right and yet you
probably haven't thought about her
except for me making this video right
and i think in a lot of ways that's how
our lives will be and it gives me a lot
of perspective in the things that we
find important and how much we value the
opinions of others when most of them
won't even remember after we die like
even a few weeks later they won't
they'll just continue to live their
lives and so if people don't even care
for more than a few weeks that we died
why do we ascribe so much value to how
they want us to live and so that has
been kind of one of the guiding
principles that i've tried to think
through with
you know how i live my life and kind of
this this next chapter and it's been
it's been a great lens for realizing
that most things just don't matter um
and that most of the meaning at least
for me comes from the things that i
choose to do meaningful rather than a
capital m meaning that has been
prescribed um from everyone else and
i'll share with you a quote that was
very meaningful to me because again this
was just a long email chain that i've
sent to myself but albert camus was a
french is a moroccan philosopher and he
said the meaning of life is why you
don't kill yourself
and that will probably trigger a lot of
people and that's not my intention but
when i heard it so succinctly stated i
thought about it i was like that might
be one of the best messages i've heard
the reason you don't kill yourself like
right now you have a reason like why
don't you do it like what is the deep
core reason for why you don't kill
yourself that reason is is your actual
meaning that is the thing that prevents
you from killing yourself and so that is
the meaning
for you and i thought that was really
fascinating now obviously for people who
have you know who follow a certain or
specific faith that is going to be maybe
the reason and if it's not the reason
then that might not be your deepest held
belief kind of interesting thought but
for me that was uh very interesting and
i'll share with you what the reason i
don't which is i i just love learning
and i just there's so much more to learn
and that's really it i just love
learning and i want to continue to learn
because i enjoy it so much and i would
be really bummed if i died because i
wouldn't be able to learn all the stuff
that i want to learn
and then uh dispelling the legacy myth
kind of once and for all my great great
grandfather was
a king or something in iran and maybe
this is folklore but doesn't really
matter because the the point of the
message is the same
i don't actually remember his name um i
think it's hormoz han but it doesn't
matter the point is i don't remember his
name and he was like royalty and he had
400 kids and he was a ruler and so think
about that from like an achievement
perspective he like ruled a country so
wealth kids fame all of those things
right and here i am only like five
generations later and i can barely tell
you his name i don't even know what he
looked like right and so i mean he
influenced my life in basically no way
besides the fact that he i was
pro-generated from him right and so we
have these ideas of legacy and they are
not real because if you just take out
the time horizon for any reasonable
period of time a thousand years ten
thousand years we will be forgotten
right but there is no legacy and so the
idea of like i want to build a legacy is
silly unless you want to say that it's
just well i'm going to leave an impact
on people and those people leave an
impact on people then cool then you just
want to help humans and that's fine but
the whole concept of being a legacy
though is kind of superfluous it's kind
of irrelevant it's just living your life
according to your values which is great
but i wouldn't necessarily call that a
legacy i have taken the stance that it's
very much a myth and that us
accumulating assets is very much like a
casino analogy that a lot of a lot of
you guys have loved from mossy nation
which is
if you imagine life as a casino where as
we come in or come of age we get a chip
and we get seated at a poker table and
we're dealt cards right and based on our
skill we're able to continually
hopefully amass chips over time and
continue to play and the difference
between a casino uh in the real world
and the casino of life is in the real
world you can cash out your chips and
walk away with more money but in the
casino of life when the green river taps
you on the shoulder and it says it's
time to go you get up from the table
your chip's still on the table and
everyone pushes it back to the middle
and then everyone redistributes those
things the lanes you own the bassets you
own etc those just get redistributed new
people own them right after you and i
remember thinking about this when i had
bought a piece of land and i was like
this is cool i own this land and then i
realized that that land had been bought
from another guy who'd been bought from
another guy who'd been bought from
another guy every person before me had
been like this is mine but not really we
just kind of lease it while we're alive
and then we die and then we give it back
and then someone else takes it right and
so
death taxes everyone 100 and so that
thought process for me has led to you
know the decision that layla and i had
which is to give away our wealth when we
die no matter what because we don't
think it's good for anybody to inherit
tremendous wealth because we think it
ruins the person and if we're going to
give it back to humanity anyways then
might as well just be more targeted in
how we give it right and so that has
been a lot of the thought process around
like why do we choose to do what we do
because it's one of the questions i get
on interviews a lot which is like why
are you still motivated to do it it's
like well what else would i do i can
just sit and drink pina coladas all day
that would be terrible and the process
of success for me is the process of
becoming the becoming is the is the
success and so hard work is the goal
that is the goal hard work that we find
meaningful and that is for me learning
is meaningful and i learn by doing so
that being said 2021 was also difficult
for me because it was a year that i
basically took off i did not work much
at all and that was mostly to kind of
have the full experience you know i
don't want to say i don't want to poo
poo not working without having not
worked and after not working for almost
an entire year i can tell you for me no
bueno it was very sad for me it was very
depressing for me i did not enjoy it i
did not get any meaningful it just was
it was not good very empty
and so i'll give you a couple of quick
conclusions that i had uh from that
whole year um the first thing is that uh
for me price of things no longer confers
value
which is actually kind of interesting
because when you think about it in the
beginning you can go out to a night
restaurant and it's really fancy because
it's a nice restaurant and so the fact
that you're sacrificing so much to go
out makes you enjoy it more if you save
up to buy a purse if you're a girl then
the purse is more meaningful to you but
if you can buy a purse off of you know
one minute's worth of income then a
really nice purse or the most expensive
purse off one minute's worth of income
then the person no longer has that
conferred value from the price and so
what's interesting about that though is
that it allows i feel like me now to
look at things without price altogether
because if all things cost essentially
zero then you get to just purely look at
things for what they are which is you
take out the marketing you take out the
psychology it's like do i like this
thing does it serve me does it have
function and so that has been kind of my
outcomes razor for how i deem things
more valuable to me so i realize that i
prefer just simple cotton tanks because
they are just easier for me and i like
them i don't need more expensive tanks
because i don't like them i like these
ones right
and if there's something that happens to
be more expensive and i like it the best
then i will get that right but price no
longer confers value if you don't feel
like the price gives you status because
you don't get your status from the
expensiveness of the thing or the cost
of the things that you wear kind of
interesting next was um i had the
realization that i had no way to
actually spend the amount of money that
we have accumulated over our lives and
that we continue to accumulate there's
no real way to spend it like as in
consume it like you can spend it to buy
assets for sure but then those assets
just make you more money and so
buying things for the sake of consuming
them there is a very easy limit that you
reach where they're there you don't
really get any more benefit and so
realizing that there's a diminishing
marginal return with money was like an
interesting conclusion to like realize
myself and i think what's interesting is
that having more allows you
to realize that you were just as happy
when you had less and maybe you have to
do that on your own and get there to let
me prove it to myself as les brown says
but to me it was it was just a very
interesting you know kind of realization
um the next one was as a result of this
you know dealing with tax shenanigans as
as i like to say um almost went down
this behalf of building like these
cascading trusts to decrease tax drag uh
on the exits that we had and i think it
probably would have saved me somewhere
in the neighborhood of about six million
dollars was like i just don't care
enough i'll just pay my taxes and um i
already have more than i can i can
spend or eat and move on and at the end
of the day like for me i realize that
the wealth is built through the owning
and not the selling and so the goal is
to just transact as little as possible
and just continue to build value in the
things that you do own because most
things over a very long period of time
just go up a lot and so it's all about
patience and i like this is a quote that
you can you can share but i like setting
up games where if i wait i win and so
those tend to be the games that i now
am more drawn towards whereas i feel
like when i was younger it was more like
if i can't win fast that i want to play
but now it's like i would love to have
the games where you cannot win unless
you wait because i know so few people
will play and typically the rewards are
outsized next one
was just really thinking about ownership
in general for personal belongings uh i
have still dedicated you know layla and
i know we own nothing we lease our
lifestyle and i would say that it has
been very freeing we thought about
buying a house again and we actually
ended up deciding not to do that and so
we are just leasing our lifestyle and it
is very freeing i will say that one of
the things that i also have started
asking myself as a question for
framing what someone else who's ahead of
me is doing and this might be useful for
you is a lot of times i originally would
look at what is this person doing that
i'm not doing right and so it comes from
the assumption that i need to do more
right
whereas if we come from the office
perspective of what is this person lack
that i have what is this person not
doing that i am doing i think a lot of
times there's more answers to that
question that are more meaningful than
trying to do more because at a certain
point you max out your ability to do and
if you're doing all day long right and
you're not getting to where you want to
go then what you're doing is the wrong
stuff to do and so it's not about doing
more because what you're doing is
already maxed out it's about doing less
and about doing different and so in
order to do different if you're maxed
out you must do fewer of the things
you're currently doing and so that is a
really good limits task for me to think
through what are the character traits
that someone might lack that i have what
are the activities that they are do that
are they are not doing that i am doing
so that i can look through a different
lens you know through which to improve
myself and then the final one on on
living stuff and this may have seemed a
little bit more heady than some of my
past lessons and failures but i think
part of that was just because you know
with the sale of all three businesses
and the dividends and everything like we
crossed a nine-figure net worth at you
know layla's 29 i'm 32. and so we have a
lot of summers left hopefully and so it
gives you a little bit of perspective on
like so what do i want to dedicate the
rest of my life to and so the the last
framework that i'll leave you with in
the kind of the woo-woo uh-ness of this
video is the 85-year-old decision
framework which is instead of talking to
an 85 year old which is a great thing to
do by the way if i imagine myself as an
85 year old version of me and i ask that
man for advice on what i should do in
situations a he's an [ __ ] uh always
making fun of me but beyond that i get
really really clear answers from someone
who wants truly just my best and i found
this to be a repeated theme throughout
my life is that a lot of times i know
what i need to do and i'm just not doing
it that may be true for you too is that
a lot of times we don't have as much
ignorance as we think we do we just have
a lot more fear to take that action and
so when i talk to my 85 year old self i
get a lot of clarity in terms of what
decisions i should make and more
realistically how few of them really
matter because when i think about my 85
year olds off all he ends up telling me
to do is like enjoy the enjoy it like
you're going to die and definitely don't
sacrifice anything for me like i would
give everything i have to be 32 again 85
year old self would give everything he
has all the billions of dollars just to
be 32 again and i have that gift right
now and it's kind of interesting and so
too many of you probably you know if you
could if you could give up everything
you have to get 10-year to go back in
time 10 years would you do it and it's
not to relive life from a regret
standpoint but just to have 10 more
years right of youth i think a lot of
people would do that which then gives
you a really interesting perspective on
the value of money and how we trade it
for time and living that was one of the
frameworks that i've been really
thinking a lot about when it comes to my
life the next one is about solving
problems which is a lot a lot of you
guys know that i'm a huge fan of charlie
mongers and one of the processes that he
champions is inverted thinking which is
or inverted problem solving which is
rather than asking how do i want to
solve this problem i try and destroy the
solution so for example if i wanted to
destroy my marriage what would i do
right i would probably not be loyal
right i would probably never compliment
my wife um and like you know the list
would go on right and what's interesting
about the inverted thinking process is
that you think of far more ways that are
threats
to a certain condition than you do
solutions naturally and i think it's
because our brains are wired to think of
threats right we're trying to survive
not thrive but you can use and trick
your brain into thinking of all of the
threats that could possibly come up
within a given situation and then all
you do is reverse them right and so if
you think how can i destroy my business
you know as easily as quickly as
possible what i do then you tell
yourself what those things would be
right and then all you have to do is
reverse those and those become your
strategic anchors those become the
biggest priorities in the business that
you need to do more of and so it's a
really wonderful process that has taken
me time to just
you know immediately go to that you know
first i had to think about it
deliberately and then i saw the utility
in using that framework and now i use it
quickly you know it's more top of mind
for me now that i solve more problems
through inverted thinking but it takes
time to get there and so that has been
probably something that i've worked a
lot on in 2021 that i hope serves you
but you can really solve so many
questions you know like if i wanted to
make an offer or would i if i wanted to
get something that no one would say yes
to what i do and then you put all the
things down and great do the opposite of
that right if i wanted to sell this
person what would i do great what would
i to guarantee that they would never buy
what would i do right and so you you
reverse it and then that gives you what
you need to sell and so you can solve so
many problems that way but i think it
just it triggers a different part of
your brain and you solve problems
differently a few major lessons
one is uh financing so we're gonna we're
gonna go from clouds all the way to dirt
okay so business business if you can
find people the money to pay they will
find a way to make it work and so i
think that financing is something that
is underrated i think the entire
education industry at large exists
because government gives basically free
money to anyone who wants to get
educated through student debt and
student loans and so that whole industry
probably would not exist if you know if
that student loan thing didn't happen
and so if you can find yourself in
industries where there is easier lending
you will sell more people at higher
prices just interesting lesson that was
a great reminder for me number two
whenever possible especially within
services sell to gold rather than
selling programs uh and the reason for
that is because people want to buy the
outcome they don't want to buy your
program so if someone wants to buy you
know uh they don't want to buy your gym
membership they want to buy a body they
want to buy what their body's going to
look like and so sell that it's a it's a
very interesting nuance but it's really
important when you're trying to you know
persuade someone to take action and it
creates a clear line between their
purchase and their desired end state and
so rather than sell like i said you know
a 12 week whatever sell the goal and so
i think if you can make that shift uh in
your products and services you
ultimately sell more people and have
happier customers moving along i read 70
books uh last year i barely read most of
them i skimmed the majority and that was
mostly because most of them were just
not that interesting or that good um the
books that i read intentionally last
year so i would skim thought they had
good stuff and then reread
ready fire aim which i've talked about
which is uh
masterson uh stephen schwartzman's what
it takes really good book uh conscious
capitalism i read the first half uh but
it was really good and it really shifted
how i saw business and what we want to
do with acquisition.com in terms of
giving back and helping all stakeholders
because
i'll go on the tangent that this book
led me to which is the realization that
charity as a whole is a very broken
model and so it's my belief and this is
what my you know what what i hope to
accomplish with acquisition is that
if we can create an entity that is
self-sustaining and self-growing
and continually
gives a percentage of its earnings then
we will have created a charity that
grows and fuels itself rather than
creating a charity that solicits money
because the exchange just it's just not
there it's always banking on goodwill
rather than a value exchange from
selfish people and so i think it's much
easier to focus on people's as a large
selfishness and then only have to get
one person to be more giving right which
you could make the argument that we're
being selfish by giving but whatever if
you only have to convince yourself to be
giving and then convince everyone else
to be selfish it's much easier to do
that over a longer period of time than
convince everyone else to give right
that is kind of the perspective that has
changed for me with regards to charity
and giving overall and so laila and i
have given millions now to charity and i
feel like now that we've been involved
there are things that i would want to
improve and the only solution that i
could think of was creating a true
for-profit type business that would
attract the best talent who could grow
the thing and then dedicate a specific
percentage of the profit every year no
matter what that would go to the causes
right and then that way as the company
grew
so too with the giving right rather than
always soliciting all right so that's
one of the things that the conscious
capitalism gave to me i read everything
uh that warren buffett and charlie
munger have written i read that last
year so there's the the shareholder
letters um
that uh buffett has written there's
charlie munger's almanac and there's
just basically anything that they've
written uh the transcriptions from all
of monger's speeches uh very very very
very good very impactful for me and the
almanac of naval ravicon that was a good
book uh very easy read like two hours
very very easy read i think i read it
again like literally right afterwards
very good book very very good all i have
to say about that very very good book
now let's get even more tactical social
media so um some of the things that
worked for growing these social medias
for us number one is only talk about
stuff that you know or that you have
experience or that real for you um i
think one of the things that i see that
at least turns me off when i see other
people's stuff is i see people clearly
regurgitating other people's content and
it's like this has already been said and
you're not adding to the body of
knowledge you're just
you know diluting down your version of
it and it's just not that useful right
it's just it's not value additive and so
it either has to be true because you've
done it or it is true to you and i think
that is a very good so like if you're
starting out what's true to you is that
you're trying and so that would be true
and your experiences that you're going
through are true and so that is kind of
in accordance with the whole document
don't create concept from garyvee which
is very difficult to operationalize but
at least just capturing the things that
you're going through no one can no one
can no one can claim that you are
speaking false truths like no one can
negate your truth of what you just did
right if you did this thing or you
helped this client that is true there's
no way that anyone can can say that you
didn't do that right and so you can give
your unique perspective which is adding
to the body of knowledge rather than
regurgitating stuff that you read in a
book right
which goes down to if someone has
already made it don't remake it
next one is um
i realize for me i don't want to have a
schedule
so what i mean by that is like i don't
have a schedule for posting stuff uh i'm
not a social media creator i am a
business guy you know i mean like we
take investments in e-learning and and
really internet businesses uh is is what
we focus on so you know that's where i
make my money the schedule felt very
constraining to me and when i didn't
have the schedule i ended up making more
and so that was something that i figured
out for me was useful the next one was
like why do you make stuff uh and i
think i alluded to the beginning of this
video but like making stuff there's
obviously making stuff for you know the
audience but i think for me it's making
it for me i'm making it to document so
that when i look back and i'm old and
gray and baggy and saggy i can be like
oh yeah that's what i used to think
about when i was at that point and it
give it it'll help me document my what
i'm thinking about at that time and
hopefully maybe for you if you can shift
that frame i think would be helpful and
i heard this from grant that i really
liked he said assume no one will ever
see it and make it anyways right and so
when he said that i thought that was
like it corroborated the conclusion that
i had gone to or come to next one was uh
you want to be platform specific for
formatting uh that's something that we
you know we found out like you just you
got to be platform specific and so
either learn the platform by using it or
find someone who does that was very
helpful for for us the next one is that
people feel intention more than anything
else and i think that was a big lesson
for me because like i don't sell
anything i have a book that's 99 cents
that you can get on amazon because the
cheapest they'll let me list it for is
99 cents and audible they don't even let
you list your own prices they list the
prices
people feel intention right and so i
think that people are always waiting for
the other shooter job at least for me in
my channel like when is he gonna pitch
you something like i have nothing to say
right like unless you're a company in
which case i'm buying not selling right
and so
the point here is if you're coming at it
from the right place like people are
exceptionally good at sniffing out why
people want something right like we're
very good at not being deceived like
it's very good from an evolutionary
standpoint to not get double crossed
right and so we i think we have very
good intuition to who is lying right and
so the easiest way to get people to
believe you is to tell the truth and if
you do want to sell people stuff just
tell them you're trying to sell them
[ __ ] right like in the companies when i
like when we were selling stuff i was
like i'm here to sell you [ __ ] i want to
make money that's why i'm here and i do
long-term want to make money from all
the investments that we make which these
videos do help with that to attract
internet businesses but a lot of my
intention is the fact that i know that
i'm going to die and it's not going to
matter anyways and like this is fun for
me tone like in selling matters more
than words and that was something that i
got to see firsthand i saw someone
deliver a pitch that was really bad
someone else basically go up and say the
same thing with the right tone and that
was where the intention came in and it
crushed and i think that seeing that
juxtaposition just showed me how much
more the intention in the heart behind
the action like humans are so good at
sniffing out intention we can it's just
so you have to be so perfect at lying
it's impossible and so the easiest way
to to to become to become trusted is to
be trustworthy right is to actually have
people's best interest in mind and if
you can't get that then like figure out
a way to do that and then the selling
will happen on its own the next belief
that i had that was broken was that
organic traffic is very worthwhile if
you are patient you are good enough and
i think that being good enough comes
back to the stuff i started earlier
which is only talk about stuff you know
make sure it's true because you did it
if someone else made it don't remake it
like make it for yourself assume no one
else is going to watch it and still make
it anyways and at the end of the day i
think this stuff has to be art because
you make art because you believe it
should exist not because the art's going
to do something for you true art is made
to exist because you believe it should
exist because you believe the universe
is better for it like you believe the
body of knowledge exists as a result of
this thing if you're making something to
do something it's usually not as good
and people can sense it and i think
that's where people fail with organic
marketing uh which is just like earned
media and i'll share this with you my my
youtube team bro
scott told me something uh that he said
was like his biggest learning that i'm
sharing with you from what he told me
and he was like you have the you have
the longest time horizon of anyone i've
ever worked with it's like you just
you're talking like you know five year
and ten year time horizons for like
whether we're gonna deem something
successful or not
and i you know i guess you sometimes you
adopt these things and you get so used
to it that you forget that other people
don't think that way and so i guess i'm
sharing it with you because he he seemed
to think that it was something that was
worth sharing but like time is
everything like how you think through
how
long something is going to take because
time is really just a function of your
expectations of an outcome and so if you
could extend the time horizon to
infinite then you basically remove your
expectations and when you can create
without expectations you usually end up
creating better stuff and so it's one of
those things where like you only gain
your life when you choose to give it
right you only
achieve happiness when you decide that
it's no longer a priority right and you
just start to live and accept the moment
for what it is and so i think that it's
in a lot of ways it's similar that time
horizons really feed into everything and
the most successful people that i know
have the longest horizons and in game
theory the person with the longest
horizon wins it's the difference between
finite and infinite players and so you
can literally give yourself an immediate
competitive advantage simply by thinking
i will outlast i will endure and i will
be here for a long time and you build
with that in mind right so what happens
is you just you get rid of all the
short-term plays like i was asked the
other day like why don't you create a a
no strip line and i'm like because it's
just not what's what's the point you
know what i mean um maybe i'll change my
mind later but like i just it's it's
like short-term cash grab right and so i
think it's all about being long-term
selfish rather than short-term solvers
and long-term selfishness comes from
just giving more than everyone else
which ends up benefiting humanity which
is great that humanity serves or rewards
the people who give the most which i
think is interesting moving along so we
had coveted in 2020 2021 was the
recovery for all three of our companies
it taught me a very important lesson
which is a buffett quote but market over
manager which is it is more important
the boat that you are in rather than how
hard or how well you row and um you know
our company was able to have a very
strong recovery um as a result of that
but it taught me that
we were not superman that we
are fallible that we are that we can
lose and despite how hard we row it's
you can still have harder like you can
still not achieve the outcomes that you
want and so i decided you know when when
when the flu hit or whatever that i was
not going to like we was like we're not
going to be affected by this like we've
made i was like i've made the decision
that we're not going to be affected by
this but you know my decision did not
really change reality and so it really
was very humbling for me to see that
like yes indeed market is stronger than
the manager and so that is what you know
spawned me to create the 55 minutes of
becoming a millionaire that that
presentation because it's all about
opportunity vehicles and that was a
great deal of my thinking last year in
putting together what we were doing with
acquisition.com another conversation
that i had was with perry belcher um who
told me a story and i think he's he's in
i think he's 60 hopefully perry don't
get upset with me maybe he's in his 50s
i don't know and he said that when he
looks back in his life he said three or
four huge like where he was crushing it
just home runs right where he was just
hitting it out of the park business-wise
and he said every time he did it he
thought it was because he was doing so
well he said but when he looked back on
it it was because he had hopped on a
trend that was happening that he was
unaware of and um he's like he was
selling gold by the inch at some point
like in his first big you know home run
thing and it was because uh it was a it
was gold-plated metal but it was because
the cost of gold was so expensive and so
he happened to hop onto a trend that he
was unknowing of and so people wanted
alternatives to gold right and so he was
selling something that capitalized on a
trend and it blew up and he's got a
company now that does uh you know
bookkeepers and va's and it's because
cost of wages in the u.s has skyrocketed
and there's a huge demand for offshore
services and so he's just riding that
wave and he said so you know as i've
gone on he's like i've learned a market
learn to sell i have all these skills
and expertises but a lot of times i was
just riding the market and so i think
that i too have had a little bit you
know i think i've had a little bit i've
been a little more humbled by life that
some of the biggest successes we had
have just been luck you know i mean we
were at the right place the right time
the thing is is that when those
occasions do happen uh swinging hard at
that fat pitch because you don't know
when the next one's going to come and so
i think that that was something that we
did well but i would urge you that if
you are in something and something is
gross is crushing it don't think it's
because of you but do go all in and i
think that you will be very happy with
the outcome
the market makes a lot of our success we
feel smart or dumb and it has nothing to
do with us the entire time uh was the
little little
email thread that i left to myself and
so that was uh very interesting for me
now next lesson in failure talent so a
lot of stuff on hiring and building team
because that was what was necessary for
us to to sell and obviously build the
hold code for acquisition.com so for
context uh you know everybody in the
whole call acquisition.com we've got
harvard grads we've got uh mckinsey
which is the number one consultant
management consulting from the world
recruits from there we have some of the
best strategists from vanguard which
manages six trillion dollars that we
recruited in to really get the absolute
best of the best people uh we had you
know our cfo has been cfo of a five
billion one billion seven 750 million
dollar company she's been sell side exit
16 times so very very very very well
versed experience team and so i've
learned a lot about talent um the
management the acquisition of talent and
my perspectives on business have
fundamentally changed from what they
were five years ago i used to think it
was all about strategy now i think it's
all about people and because if you find
great people great people build great
strategy and execute great strategy to
build great companies you can't build a
great company without great people and i
just i just i just really i just didn't
think that when i was younger i was like
i can will power my way through it and
it's just even if you can you can't do
it forever or maybe you can i don't know
but uh for me like at a certain point it
wasn't worth it in order to scale like
only one man only has two hands and so
you have to have more hands and you have
to more people aligned with your your
mission and so here's some of the
conclusions that i've had around talent
um over the last however long better
understanding of entrepreneurs versus
entrepreneurs so i had a big you know i
used to say like you need to find
entrepreneurs not entrepreneurs silly it
was a false binary entrepreneurs and
entrepreneurs exist on a continuum you
have some people here either more or
less entrepreneurial and all of those
things can change given a dynamic plenty
of people were employees got laid off
and coveted then and decided to start
making money on their own and then found
out they did have an entrepreneurial
streak right and so i used to think that
this was much more like born and i think
now that it's much more made and i never
would have considered myself a big risk
taker
i did everything by the book you know
for basically all my career and i was
only very lucky that i hated my life so
much that i was willing to quit
everything
to start a business but that is not
common and it was still one of the
hardest decisions of my life and seeing
how easily some people quit their jobs
compared to how long it took me to do it
even when i had no stake i had no family
had no kids it was still the hardest
decision my entire life i really do
think more and more that entrepreneurs
are made rather than born and it is
again a continuum and that continuum can
change uh where you sit on that
continuum can change based on your
circumstances right and so i think that
there's this like he's a pure
entrepreneur he's not a pre-entrepreneur
and to me i feel like it's like in this
context for right now and that can
change so that was something that i
thought was interesting and in that way
when we're recruiting talent i'm not
really looking necessarily for
entrepreneur entrepreneur it's just like
is this person aligned with where we
want to go and are they motivated
intrinsically by getting there right if
so then they will be entrepreneurial if
we can create the environment such that
those character traits come out and i'll
tell you the one thing that sealed the
deal for this is that layla's father is
the or was the dean of mechanical
engineering department so academic you
know all the way tenure the whole like
literally the most secure security you
know driven career path of all time
and i remember saying i was like if he
can start doing entrepreneurship i was
like i will change all of my views
because i mean literally like an
engineer in academia tenure like it's
just like all of the most security
driven things and lo and behold here he
is now you know starting his
entrepreneurial dream that now that he
retired and he's making money and i like
i'm just filled with pride uh seeing
that but at the same time it just it
gave it just it was such a testament to
the fact that we can change our stars we
can be what we want to be and that was
just such a big profound proof point for
me that it really shifted the way i saw
talent and entrepreneurship in general
next one was uh in terms of finding
talent it has now been my it's now my
feeling that it's better to find a 400
batter than to teach someone how to
swing right i would rather find people
who are really really good already and
then orient them rather than try and
teach someone how to do the thing right
now you might not be able to afford that
at a certain point in your business
career but that is still the ideal that
i would that would go towards and if you
look at what you know steve jobs you
know was able to do in his in his career
he was really the assembler of great
people towards a common mission and goal
and that is what creates big companies
is lots of people align in a specific
direction to something that is
meaningful which again if the point of
your company is to make you money it's
not that meaningful for a lot of people
and so it has to be something bigger
than you and that again is something
that i had to learn once you do that you
need to get out of their way really and
so i have a friend of mine who owns a
company and he's uh ceo of that company
and the founder of the company you know
made him ceo but he has become he's not
really a ceo by the true sense that he's
not actually executing and like leading
uh the stuff because the founder is
micromanaging which either means one of
two things you either don't trust the
person
to to do their job or you're not good at
hiring people that's it it's like either
the person has the talent and you need
to trust them or they don't have the
talent which means you suck at hiring
but either way we suck and so
once you do have the right person we
have to extend trust even if that person
hasn't quote earned it yet because it's
the only way that the machine runs and
trust is typically reciprocal and
sometimes you have to give it first and
you will make more by giving it than by
deciding to live a life without trust
even if you get burned
so that was been a lesson for me um from
the last year one of the next ones was
uh a players are the things that really
grow business and
like once you get stuck at like 30ish
million and i've said this said this and
i will say it again i was stuck there
for for almost four years right and the
thing that that got me out of that was
realizing that i it was kept being me i
kept trying to make me the center but it
had to be everyone else it had to be
other leaders it had to be other people
driving the growth and setting up the
incentive such that like they can win
big time not just little time big time
and uh part of that i got from
schwartzman's book in order to attract
level 10 talent you have to have a level
10 opportunity and most people are not
actually pursuing level 10 opportunities
they're just trying to make some money
and so if you want to attract the best
people and work with the best people you
have to be going after the big stuff the
big goals right and it is just as hard
to accomplish a big goal as it is a
little goal and it takes just as long so
you might as well go big that leaves me
the next one which is a character and
values must be present in order to
attract caliber people right high
caliber people and so i think one of the
hardest parts of entrepreneurship is the
leadership component because it's it's
the most raw it's who you are right
people have to buy into you because like
you as you grow like
get go up in the in the ranks like
you're not going to be smarter than the
people you hire like a lot of people
that work at acquisition.com are smarter
than i am like i mean that generally
that's not just like me paying lip
service like they're very smart and
they're smarter especially in their
domains than i am the only way to
attract those people is obviously to
have a mission that that makes sense
that they want to be a part of like i
had to change i have to be better right
this is adopted from mongers you know
things of living an excellent life but
it's living a life without envy it's
living a life without resentment a
living a life of discipline of not
overspending means remaining charitable
despite circumstance dealing with
reliable people and doing what you say
you're going to do and what you were
supposed to do those are very easy to
say very hard to do and i think that if
we hold those as ideals we can just keep
walking towards them without with
knowing wholeheartedly that we will
never achieve perfection but the process
itself can be a perfect process even if
you have an imperfect outcome and so in
that way we can be joyful in our
imperfection because we are following a
perfect process so to me that's very
cool but i think that if we view our
leadership as a process of becoming
rather than getting there then we will
attract people who also want to walk in
that path alongside us so that was from
a talent perspective major lessons time
horizons if you can extend them you will
win sometimes we need to eat [ __ ] for an
extended period of time and uh
entrepreneurship is a battle of will not
intellect and that was something that i
learned especially in 2021 um and 2020.
it is a battle of will not intellect i'm
just going to say it again i don't know
what you're doing right now it is a
battle of will not intellect because
since it is an infinite game which means
that the point of the game is to keep
the game going the point of the game is
to keep playing not to win right because
there is no winning you realize there is
no winning so if the point of the game
is to keep playing then it's about will
it's about the will to endure it's about
the will to continue and so if you can
frame it that way then the game gets
much easier because you realize there
are no wins and losses as long as you're
playing and if it is a game then what
better to do in life than play next one
is the importance of frame so this one
is a really insane story and i'm gonna
try and tell it as short as i can dean
graziosi who's now become a very close
personal friend uh he told me this story
that just blew me away so if you don't
know who he is he uh dean has is one of
if not the best marketer out there he's
unbelievable he's tony robbins right
hand man he's the main driver behind you
know the business machine that works
there and he also has his own brand and
they're all mass market and he had
multiple brands before that motor
millions and real estate and he's done a
lot of stuff and he told me about this
um ad that he ran and he was his perfect
dad that he ran with larry king and he
did this book interview and he was like
it was the perfect interview i knew was
gonna crush as an infomercial and then
it bombed and he's like and he watched
the whole thing and he knew it was going
to be awesome he didn't get it so he
flew larry king live out because he
looked at all of his best winning
infomercials and he looked at his and he
thought that the first two sentences of
the one hour-long segment needed to be
changed and so he flew him back out he
did he redid the entire setup of larry
king live
covered all the expenses just so he
could re-record the first two sentences
and he re-recorded the first two
sentences and then that infomercial did
100 million dollars plus
in sales
and to me the biggest lesson there from
a marketing perspective but also from a
psychology perspective was the frame is
everything how you frame a conversation
how you frame a situation how you frame
a circumstance to yourself or others
will massively change how they
perceive
the remaining information that they that
gets transmitted to them and so when
we're selling how we set the frame when
we're trying to persuade our team how we
set the frame when we want to make an
offer how we set the frame when we want
to make an ad how we set the frame are
so important and if we look back on the
best ads that you have those hooks you
know uh ogilvy i think said uh once
you've ridden your headline you've spent
80 cents out of your dollar in
advertising and so realizing that that
frame is so important has really made me
rethink a lot of the things that i think
about in our ads our copy headlines etc
and how much more time needs to be
allocated to that if 80 percent of your
dollar is spent on the headline then you
should spend 80 on that piece right on
just perfecting it i'll tell you in the
split test that we run things like that
it's been bar none
crazy to see
how different just these tweaks are just
on the headlines themselves and so the
next one i want to cover is people are
either helping you become the person you
want to be or they are not there is no
in between and so we have these people
that we have in our lives and i think
sometimes it was useful for me to kind
of take inventory of like who are the
people that when i see their name on my
phone i get a pang of cortisol like i
get a little bit of stress because i
think they're taking something from me
and when i actually looked through my my
text messages it was 41 of texts were
something that caused me stress and i
was like well [ __ ]
half i was like no wonder i hate my
phone right and so piece by piece trying
to remove
uh people or just slow down the the
communication cycles with people that i
thought were draining me has been a very
good process for me overall for thinking
clarity and for accomplishing what i
want to accomplish and so i don't know
where you're at and the people but i
think if you can take inventory of like
and i just feel like the easiest litmus
test is look at your phone look through
your last week of texts and then think
about which of these people are trying
to take something from you and if you
can slowly phase those people out and
only have more of the people who
energize you i think life is just better
right because if you lose your phone and
you're happier as a result of it it
makes you really wonder why you have a
phone
success must be measured through
multiple metrics so this was a huge one
for 2021 for me is that and this is a
quote from charlie munger is that
someone is always doing better right
someone's always doing better than you
and so in in one aspect and so i think
it's useful to have multiple metrics for
measurements so you can have your body
you can have your marriage you can have
your finances you can have your business
you can have your team you can have your
kids you can have whatever like multiple
metrics for success and in 2021 in my
direct income not including the the sale
numbers it was a medium year for me but
for my marriage it was an amazing year
and i'd say like we you know we three
axed our marriage uh last year but it
was a great great year for our marriage
and so i think that and i think about 85
year old me looking back it's like yes
good like multiple metrics for success
and so i think measuring those things
has been helpful for me when i think
about a year of lessons and failures
that was a good that was a plus in the
plus column because i didn't used to do
that the only goals i ever said were
financial
and so i think now i think i think more
a little bit more holistically
next one is uh simple attainable goals
create crazy
growth
one of the things is like now that we
work with you know a lot of portfolio
companies that are in internet
businesses that are doing you know three
million plus et cetera
we set goals with them a lot right and a
lot of times i see the goals that they
want to set them just these massive
goals and the thing is is that
when we extend the time horizon
if you can get a 10 or 20 per quarter
growth
that's unbelievable and that adds up
very very very very fast but everyone
wants to double every 90 days and that's
just not realistic and so they always
fall short and so i have been a big
proponent of how can we set a goal
that's impossible for us to hit and then
let's crush it halfway through the
quarter and then reset the goal because
i feel like it's better to just keep
setting goals and keep crushing goals
than to set goals and then miss them
everyone has different psychologies
around this but for me i like to make a
commitment and stick with it and know
that i'm going to hit it that has been
very helpful and i think as i've gotten
older in entrepreneurship i have set
more and more reasonable goals and i
think that as a result of that we
actually grow more consistently and
build a better company because we're not
trying to
do something crazy to hit a goal
for no reason because it's arbitrary we
set up the timeline so if we set the
timeline way way way in the future and
we know that we can just hit these basic
benchmarks over a longer period of time
we're going to build something huge and
it's just thinking like that is what
unlocks the huge growth potential that
time provides next one um contrarian
investing so you must be willing to do
the unpopular thing to be against the
cycle right when everyone's worried
right like when everyone's buying and
buying inflated prices that's when you
have to hold and just wait i look at
uncle warren and he's got 25 of his uh
of his assets in cash right now like
that's a little interesting to me best
investor of all time he's seen every
cycle imaginable he understands stuff
better than anyone he's probably also
more connected and he's got 25 in cash
interesting right very very interesting
the next one is from an investing
standpoint um laila and i have really
committed just only investing in things
we know which is why we work with
internet businesses because it's the
business as we know right and so
sticking with that as our primary thesis
so like there's something that you do
know better than other people stick with
that for us we limited real estate we
still have you know a portfolio in real
estate but it's limited due to the fact
that like i don't have skill or
experience in that and i can get
outsized returns doing the thing that
i'm good at right and an interesting
thing is like if you get 10x on one
tenth of your money you still have 100
irr
right and so if you're worried about
inflation for all of your money it's
like if you get crazy returns on 20 of
your money it still covers your your
whole nut right and so i think that's
always making sure that you have the
downside of mitigation you buy with a
margin of safety right which is again
uncle warren a couple things on time so
i've realized that for me meetings on
mondays work great so i just always just
throw mondays up as like this is the day
that i do for meetings that's that right
i just accepted that as as a reality for
me so people ask me about how my life
looks that's how it looks mornings are
sacred for me and so for me morning is
until i lunch so basically 4 5 6 a.m
until noon is my time to do stuff and i
think that that has probably been one of
the
most integral habits that i have had in
my life which is that i just get all my
[ __ ] done before lunch after lunch i do
all my meetings and all my calls and all
those things because my creative juice
if i if i take meetings first thing my
creative juice is spent and i can't work
after but if i do creative stuff in the
morning i still feel like i'm very
effective on meetings after that first
for whatever reason and that works for
me some people might be opposite but i
think having that dedicated time is
really important some people work and
then they love working from like
whatever you know eight o'clock at night
until two in the morning everyone's
different but for me having that
dedicated time has been super important
next one i want all of my i like having
space uh to do free things on my
calendar and so when i have everything
every minute booked um and this has
changed over time for me and maybe it'll
change again in the future but i get i
stress out and i feel like i'm less
productive and so having free time to
think and create ultimately produces
outsized returns it's just not as
reliable or at least rather as it is
more volatile in nature so i might have
a free day and not get anything done and
then i might have a free day and crush
it but i know that having free days
makes me more than never having free
days
hopefully that makes sense next one is
that writing next books so i think a lot
of people underestimate how much time it
takes to make something that's excellent
and the difference between good and
great is fast and so uh when we're
making products i share this story
because i think it will resonate with
someone like writing this book uh took
me a really long time right and that's
why i think it ended up being uh pretty
decent because we spent so many times
rewriting it like i rewrote this book
four times
end to end the leads book i've now i'm
on my sixth version and it's still not
done yet because it's it's honestly a
more complicated topic and it just takes
it just takes work sometimes the work
just needs doing for it to be excellent
and so that is just a reminder more than
it is a lesson and it's for myself
included
because i get impatient i want to send
you guys the next book i want to publish
it but like it's just not there and i'm
also doing all the other stuff and so it
will happen when it happens and i
promise that if it you know has my name
on it and i'm saying it's great then it
is my best effort to be exceptional and
worthy of your time
next one is uh supply and demand i have
i feel like every few years i get like a
new level of depth on my on my
understanding my perceived understanding
of those two forces
but
man supply and demand drive price just
so much i just
and what's crazy is that you have you
can influence demand by being persuasive
right in that you can channel more of it
towards you it's even easier to
influence supply uh and so it's it's so
it's so interesting to put limits on
things and again it's very counter-human
right we think if we limit things we
will make less money but a lot of times
when we limit things we make more money
which is why a limited swag drop makes
more money than always have the t-shirt
on your website and so creating and
imposing limits creates clarity of
thinking it creates clear value and you
actually end up getting more people who
want it because it is scarce
and so i'm continually re-re-taught
i relearned this lesson in different in
different ways and it's been very
valuable and so like for us you know
acquisition.com we're taking on internet
businesses it's like
we have a lot of people who who reach
out um and we just the reason that we
have such high returns with the
companies and they grow so well is
because
we
have no need to take anyone i don't we
don't need to do any of it and so
we just get to pick the ones that we
want to do for a long time because we
want to do it and because we think we
can absolutely kill it and i think that
having that i don't like there's no need
there's no scarce there's no there's no
vacuum that needs to get filled there's
no short-term arbitrary goal that we're
trying to hit it's just for the love of
the game and as a result of the
long-time horizon you can have more
scarcity because there is no arbitrary
goal that we need to hit and in so doing
you create better outcomes which is
again so counter-intuitive that it
drives me nuts but it's also like the
one of the beautiful things with life
that i feel like i'm learning right now
and so
anyways i to me that's like a very
beautiful contrast um that i figured i'd
share with you just the idea that the
perceived supply and demand are really
the only factors that influence price
and we can control both of those things
and especially how few things we want to
sell if it comes to our time our
attention etc and a lot of us we better
serve just limiting the amount of people
and actively saying i'm only doing this
once that cap is met being done it's
amazing how good it feels to say like i
have hit
like i we are we are where we need to be
that is all we don't there is no need
for more we have enough right and then
when you so choose to you have built up
sufficient demand that when you open up
the door
the slots fill back up and you can close
it again right and it's much better to
always know where your next nail is
coming from i think emotionally than to
never know and always feel like you are
wanting and craving more and so it's
been an interesting process
to kind of like walk through that and i
think a lot of service-based businesses
would be very well served properly
utilizing scarcity to better serve their
customers to increase their margins and
ultimately provide a better experience
overall because they're not doing it
because they have some arbitrary goal
that they just like set and they're like
i want to hit a million a month for no
reason right why
why
right if you can answer that question i
guarantee you'll hit it
last one last last major lesson topic
for me was uh
leverage the amount we make amount of
money we make is directly
proportionately amount of leverage that
we are able to employ you know naval has
his his his four that he talks about i
renamed them as c's so i could remember
it but you've got collaboration which is
employing other people you've got
capital which is using other people's
money you've got code which is using
software and you've got content or media
right which is
all of these things
especially the top two you can
replicate without cost right like if two
people use a software 100 people use the
software there's very little additional
cost if one person watches this video or
a thousand people watch this video
there's no added cost to me for capital
if i can use other people's money right
then i can grow something faster if i
can use other people's time when it
comes to labor then i can do more right
and so i think understanding how to use
all four of those things is one of the
things that unlocks true wealth and so i
would encourage you and this has been a
process that i've taken
i've really geeked out on but look at
the wealthiest people in the world and
look at the people around you who are
succeeding who are growing quickly and
look at which of those four c's if one
two three four or all of them they are
using to grow
their businesses
and so now when i look at opportunity
it's how can i employ the most leverage
and the opportunity because then all
leverage does is give you higher output
per unit of effort or time that's all it
is if we only have limited time the
extent to which we can multiply that
time is an extent to which we're
employing leverage which is the
multiplier and so these are all
multipliers in and of themselves if you
look at facebook they used they have
labor there's lots of employees who are
working there there's capital they used
other people's money to grow the
business there's code which is the
software base that the whole thing is
built on and they sell media it's all
four right all four things are created
and that's why the thing is the empire
that it is you can see how people are
employing these things together you look
at uh grant and some of you guys for
some reason like poo poo the fact that
like i've even talked to grant which is
beyond silly to me whenever someone's
doing better than you at anything
there's something we can learn from them
right and so
like i'm okay i'm gonna i'm gonna talk
to your heart for a second
it is your ego
that is fragile
that makes you
not want to learn from someone else
who's doing better than you in some way
because you feel like it makes you suck
and you want to give an excuse for why
someone else has achieved more than you
in that way well he doesn't have the
ethics that i have well he has better
genetics well blah blah he was born
better looking whatever it is right for
the wife right whatever it is
it doesn't serve you
and i say this as somebody who used to
do that a lot
and so i realized that i was not getting
any better by giving up all my excuses
for why i wasn't achieving what someone
else was achieving and so the biggest
goal was to reframe my envy into
curiosity which is how are they doing
that and how am i not doing as well as
them if i claim to be all these things
then the reality should match that and
it's not and so i will break down why i
think um i think grant's gonna multiply
by a lot like a lot a lot i'll tell you
why
so one he knows how to he knows how to
galvanize people towards a cause so he
knows how to employ and and and have
people aligned so that's he's got
collaboration the next level is he's got
capital he's raising tons and tons and
tons of money to to buy stuff and he's
got tons and tons of content and uh the
next move that i think he's going to
make is um is around starting a bank and
i think it'll be one of the most
brilliant moves that he makes because
what's even easier than getting someone
to invest just get someone to save and
what'll be cool is that what is going to
happen is he's going to have so many
deposits into cardone bank that he can
then use that money to go to the fed and
he can lever bank rates of leverage um
and then buy way more stuff to get
returns on that because people are still
too chicken [ __ ] uh to make investments
for themselves so they're just gonna
bank and he'll give them a better return
on their money than the banks are and
he'll be able to suck so much cash from
the universe of his audience and that he
will get so much leverage on those
things that he's gonna buy i think it's
gonna be a really really cool thing to
say
and so anyways i think they're in that
way we can learn of him now does he have
any does he have any code no he's got
three other four maybe he'll be able to
embed that stuff in later maybe he won't
i don't know and so the thing is is like
you don't need to have all of them but
the more of them you have the more
multiplicative the effect is on the
ultimate amount of money that you make
and when someone goes from you know zero
to billionaire in a decade i think we
can all learn something from it and i
certainly
am trying to analyze everything that
someone is doing much better than i am
um is doing right especially with the
same period of time like why i was alive
10 years ago and he was live 10 years
ago and he became a billionaire in that
time and i did not become a billionaire
therefore he is better at this game than
i am right now right
and so um
i just think it's really valuable to
look at that way the last piece is uh
seasons of waiting
waiting
and in action are active decisions
charlie marvel talks about this when it
comes to investing he's like not selling
is an active decision all you have to do
is look at the markets because people
cannot hold themselves back
it's not that we are doing nothing we
are doing nothing get the difference
we're not doing nothing we're doing
nothing and that was the active decision
we chose to make and so sometimes we
just need to wait and that was something
that i feel like i learned last year as
well was that you know you can't you
can't uh
you can't have you can have you can't
get nine women pregnant for a month to
have a baby right like some things take
time i think an acceptance of a
different view on time has been
something that shaped
my life for the better and i can tell
you the people unequivocally that make
the most money that i know all speak in
the longest time horizons and the people
who make the least amount of money
unequivocally talking the shortest time
horizons the people who talk about today
tomorrow next week this month make less
money than the people we're talking
about five years from now without fail
and so if that's all you can think about
which is what are we making this month
what are making this week what are we
making today right you need to extend
your time horizon because when you do
that you think smart because you think
long and when you think long you make
games where if you wait you win and so
mosey nation those are the lessons and
failures from 2021 those are things that
i learned that were very valuable to me
i made another video about just lessons
that i learned from the sale which i
think i might have made a little bit too
technical
and i have another video that i made uh
about how to sell a business uh that was
very in-depth as well in terms of the
actual process of selling so i get lots
of questions around that and so um check
out those videos if you did and as
always love you all and i'll see you
guys next video keeping awesome bye